and finally new rule instead of putting
a bible in hotel rooms we should start
putting a dictionary in there
[Applause]
because apparently nobody knows what
words mean anymore
george carlin famously had the seven
words you can't say on tv
well
here's my eight words people need to
stop redefining
hate victim hero shame violence survivor
phobic and white supremacy
comedian
hannah gadsby characterized dave
chappelle's controversial netflix
special as hate speech dog whistling
well dog whistle refers to when someone
puts things in code because they're
afraid to come out and say what they
really think
that's what you get from dave chappelle
he's afraid to say what he really thinks
[Music]
and it's not hate speech just because
you disagree with it nor is it phobic
phobic comes from the greek word for
something one fears irrationally like
spiders or germs
but now is used as a suffix for anything
you just don't like
i've been called commitment phobic no i
i don't fear commitment i just don't
want it
[Applause]
no
other people do great
i don't call them single phobic
i don't like bowling i'm not bowling
phobic
and if i talk about how wrong i think it
is to force women to wear a beekeeper
suit all day
that's not being islamophobic i just
don't like it
and i bet they don't either
i went as a ghost for halloween once i
lasted about 20 minutes
also in the category of we just don't
like it so we're pretending it's
something else is the word violence
last year there was a staff mutiny at
the cbs drama all rise when some of the
writers
i'm sorry i meant victims
took issue with a scene where two women
are in an elevator and a naked man gets
on and they just continue talking calmly
and if you think that's offensive you
should see how the guy pushed the button
[Applause]
but the writers on this show found the
scene objectionable and sent off an
email saying
two women would not calmly continue a
conversation with a naked white guy
running into the elevator that is
violence
no it's not
violence is when it hurts it usually
involves leaving a mark of some kind
of course innumerable things can lead to
violence but i'm sorry you can't take
that word and use it for stuff that's
just scary to you or just verbal which
is something i literally learned in
kindergarten
sticks and stones may break my bones but
if you don't know how that one ends you
need to repeat kindergarten
social justice warriors who are fond of
governing by hashtag like to say silence
is violence
and we know that because it rhymes
the words victim and survivor have
traveled
a long way from their original usage the
baby from the nirvana album says he's a
victim he's suing nirvana for lifelong
damages
i never thought i'd have to say this to
a baby but stop being such a [ __ ]
baby
you're not a victim there's no reason
you can't have a normal happy life just
because people look at you and think
baby penis
it didn't hurt trump
in 2010 the new york times used the term
white supremacist on 75 occasions last
year over 700 times now some of that to
be sure is because trump came along and
emboldened the faction of this country
that is truly white supremist it is of
course still a real thing
but it shouldn't apply to something like
as more than a few have suggested
getting rid of the s.a.t test
now if we find the s.a.t test is slanted
in such a way as to stack the deck in
favor of caucasians if there are
questions like
biff and chip are selling a yacht
traveling at 12 knots to an ed sheeran
concert on catalina
if catalina is 26 miles away how many
white claws should they bring
yes
then maybe
but of course the s.a.t doesn't have
questions like that so it becomes a kind
of ludicrous exaggeration that makes
lovers of common sense roll their eyes
and then vote for trump
now are there snowflakes on the right of
course there's no whinier little [ __ ]
than trump himself
but this
but this kind of stuff does tend to
stick to the left a lot more have you
ever heard a parent call their child
their hero
what party are they probably in
my kid is my hero why he's six did he
pull something out of a burning building
my hero look at the way he shares his
ritalin
you do realize how stupid it sounds to
imply you want to grow up to be your kid
during the pandemic everyone was a hero
now for sure frontline medical workers
really were and are
but then it spread to civil servants and
then anyone who just went to work
postal employees amazon stalkers one day
i found myself saying to the guy
collecting carts at ralph's thank you
for your service
[Applause]
and then there's shaming
that definition has been rewritten to
mean anything that suggests i'm not 100
perfect
i'm not fat shaming when i call [ __ ]
on the idea that a person can be healthy
at any size we're so through the looking
glass on this that weight watchers
change their name to ww
the weight loss people can't mention
weight loss
adele was shamed for losing weight like
she was a traitor to what unhealthiness
when i have reported the statistic that
78 of the people who died or were
hospitalized with covert were overweight
that's not fat shaming that's fat
splaining
it's what
it's what the cdc should be doing and
this is the essence of why word
inflation is a problem you can try to
change reality by changing the words
but you can't it just stops you from
dealing with it one of the bad guys in
1984 says the whole aim of newspeak is
to narrow the range of thought
yes it's orwellian and you know what
they say orwell never ends well
you